I might see it she said you wronged me
you said something about me that wasn't
true and if she doesn't forgive me I'm
gonna give whatever goodies if I have to
her woman wasn't allowed in a nightclub
after refusing to remove her hijab now
when you read that statement
it sounds shocking as a Muslim man or a
woman be a brother or sister whoever it
may be when you hear these things or if
it was a a headline of Muslim man caught
drinking alcohol whatever it may be it
obviously hurts a Muslim why does it
hurt us because we love for our brothers
and sisters what we love for our self so
when we see our brothers sisters falling
short like myself I fall short in a lot
of things we hate it in our hearts why
because the process is seldom said if
you see an evil try to stop it if you
caught something with your hand stop it
with your tongue if you can't speak out
against it at least hit it in your heart
that's the reason we hate it not because
we dislike the person however sometimes
personally myself was the reason why I'm
doing this video is that sometimes we
fall short sometimes we make mistakes
and we are human beings and that is
exactly what this video is going to be
about it's going to be about my public
repentance yes I'm publicly retracting
what I said about our dear sister and
also I'll be publicly repenting and I
ask Allah subhana WA Ta'ala to forgive
me for myself sharing an information
from a unreliable source jump in on the
bandwagon unintentionally because of you
can just call it whatever you like just
rush you know just being rush and
sharing this information without
verifying it with our sister herself I
tried to get in contact with her from
Facebook and asked for her to forgive me
for doing so and hopefully when she was
talking about the Haram please I was on
one of those I don't feel I'm doing
myself leave myself as one now what I
found really beautiful is it reminded me
of a verse channel 49 verse 6 Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala says something which I
looked at this verse and I said Ali
that's you I was isn't all right o you
who believe if a simple person brings
you a report verify its correctness lest
you should harm a people out of
ignorance and then become remorseful on
what
you did brothers and sisters if this is
not to me I do not know who it is I am a
public figure I should be careful to
what I do I should not just go out there
have hazard Li and say things yes and
that's why I repent publicly why because
the sin that I done that I did was
publicly and that's one of the things
that we try to advise our different
youtubers in the Muslim scene so you see
people think that we just have a got
other people for no reason we don't look
the last thing I want to do is take time
that's my you know I'm busy working and
off things to go and just look for
people's fault I don't do that I try my
best assume the best and try to
privately advise but when some people
send in public we have to advise and
refute their misguidance in public now
myself I am one of those I'm repeating
myself I did this sin in public and it
requires a public retract meant not only
that it requires a public repentance and
that's the reason why I'm doing this
video because I spread an information
which was false about our sister now I
came to know that okay wasn't a night
Palooza pub regardless non-carbon Palma
two separate things
yeah there's two separate things you can
go to a pub no it's not allowed to go to
a pump I'm just saying that if you do
you know there's alcohol section some
some you go to it's like a hotel the pub
is there so it's a whole different
storage again and we have to assume the
best in our sister and that's a reminder
to myself first
I caused harm and I'm remorseful like
the Koran says in chapter 49 verse 6 and
I also lost wants Allah forgive me and
brothers and sisters I want to make
something very clear that when it comes
to these things do not be those among
people who try to look for other
people's faults I do not go and like
I've got nothing better to do
let me go on the internet and let me
search what I can find today these
videos take time I finished work I
should be home now but with these kind
of videos sometimes we have to come out
and do it I'm just talking our general
in general in other things as well so do
not see this as some kind of like oh
well I bored and you know some people
come and say oh why'd you have to react
to everything I'm just bored
the profile decide what I said I've got
nothing better to do I'm just like you
know what let me just react for the sake
of a brother the sisters we do these why
because I thought if there is sisters
out there who may have then I thought
she actually did this
she hasn't that she may fall into this
just to give them in the seer and said
look you know you have a religious
comment etc try to I've seen from these
kind of places because why firstly is
Haram etc and and don't get confidence
there's a lot of sisters that do go you
know sadly in their stomach attire you
know they go in that stomach that's
higher so it's really really important
for us to advise one another the first
time said the Dean isn't a seer we only
do it why because we want good for each
other
your friend is not the one who Pat's you
on the back of every Haram that you do
says yeah yeah go ahead
you go girl yeah do whatever you like
this is sorry this is not your friend
this is your biggest enemy a friend is
that the one who advises you so
inshallah I make this clear
I ask the sisters forgiveness if you can
share this video with her I genuinely
ask for forgiveness because it was wrong
it was false information about her if
that was done towards my sister I'll be
very upset and they have a right to be
upset and I asked him to forgive me
because it reminds me that on the day of
judgment and this was reminded that was
sent to me that they were showing
different journeys that were going to
take and after we crossed the Sirat
we're Hellfires gonna be believe us once
we go past there we're gonna be thinking
up great if I've made it for here I'm
going gender well there's going to be a
part between the Surat and gender where
you are going to be accounted for the
wrong button you did to others and
subhanAllah you are going to imagine
that this is very very profitable
assistance if we have wronged other
people yeah intentionally taking their
money going against their rights oppress
them whatever whatever it may be
yeah you are going to be questioned
there and you know how it's going to
work that person that you wrong is going
to be in front of you and they're going
to say this person violated this and
this and this right of mine yeah so if
miss sister doesn't forgive me I might
see her off maihama
and I was enter paradise and her and a
whole family I might see it she said you
ruined me you said something about me
that wasn't true and if she doesn't
forgive me
I'm gonna give whatever goodies if I
have to her yeah so whatever like I say
I don't know what good is that I'm gonna
have to give something to her now if I
don't have any good deeds at all guess
what I'm going to take I'm going to take
her sins on my on my portion yeah of my
bad deeds so if I have good deeds I'm
gonna be giving that to her some whether
it's due to her based on her right
if not I have no deeds I will be taking
her bad deeds of her yeah and taking the
burden of our bad deeds bothers and
sisters and some may come and say okay
hold on a second are for Allah says in
the Quran nobody carries a burden of
another well it doesn't but I'm not
carrying her but I'm carrying the burden
that I caused to myself by talking about
her and a prisoner so it's very
important brothers and sisters for us to
understand because people that you
wronged slammed aback by take all kinds
of stuff from them or press them you're
going to be in trouble so I hope this is
a lesson for myself for public refuting
my own self and for us to be careful and
verify information and thirdly thirdly
to understand that there's going to be
consequences every single person that
you wrong it's going to get there right
for me we ask Allah subhana WA Ta'ala to
forgive us and the way of repenting
bothers and sisters is number one you
stop the same you hate the sin you don't
go back to the sin that's if you've
wronged against Allah you've done a sin
generally if you roam the person you
have to ask their forgiveness that's the
reason why I'm asking the sisters
forgiveness and I ask her to forgive me
and I would be very very careful in what
I'm sharing in the future may Allah
bless you guys and I would really
appreciate this sister can forgive me
and just some kind of communication by
her brother whoever just say no she's
forgiven me and also lost parents Allah
forgive me and teach me a lesson through
this that we do not fall among those
Allah says that you know we don't verify
information from an evil source like
mirror or wherever is good but on
sisters may Allah bless you guys so guys
it benefitted from this to share this
with your friends and family
- next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullah better care -